since after this tutorial is lunch I
don't think I should wait I should get
started there'll be lots of pauses
throughout throughout the session so if
you're still getting things downloaded
and getting things set up don't worry
you'll get a chance to catch up if you
need a USB sticks with the data set and
we have a couple that have the the
notebook that I'm going to walk through
we we have those as well so just raise
your hand but i'll get started can
everyone hear me in the back yeah good
alright so this morning I want to cover
a few different things let's do it we'll
do a brief introduction then we're going
to jump in and do some data engineering
and feature engineering we'll do some
modeling we're going to spend some time
talking about sentiment analysis and how
how useful it is and techniques for for
building sentiment analysis models and
then we'll talk through deploying those
types of models as a service so you guys
are here at the the introduction to
machine learning applications tutorial
hopefully that's a that's where you're
supposed to be where you want to be I'm
going to paste things with pauses so
feel free to follow along you don't have
to when i get to writing stuff on the
notebook it might go a little quickly so
that i can i can help folks that are
having trouble but you should be able to
follow along and if you're after getting
stuck please interrupt us raise your
hand we've trying to address questions
and problems throughout the session when
I keep saying we let me introduce the
two of us that will be presenting so I'm
rashad and brian from is here from dado
so we also have Alesia in the corner
from dado as well so we're three folks
that will be here throughout the session
with you guys so you can see the
notebook is still the notebook I didn't
finish until last night so that's why I
didn't put it on the USB keys but you
should be able to get to it from that
link so I'd love to know a little bit
about the room so let's start there so
how many of you have heard of dado all
right is it because of all the signage
here be honest with me
ya know you know about us beforehand
good alright GraphLab any folks that
didn't know about data a new about
GraphLab all right we're the same group
same group of people same project same
come and now we're a company so about
you guys how many folks consider
themselves data scientists all right
data architects all right data engineers
all right pipe anis does oh come on
right the PI data conference no we're
not all Python ESA's okay and what else
I only saw half the hands go up so what
what do the ret what's that no they're
shy I was like that's not a job I know
about that's okay well I'd love to find
out what what you guys work on if it's
not any of these things so I should give
you a brief intro about dado just so you
understand what we do as a company I
thought the best way to do that is to
show you a few demos I'm not going to go
through a big pitch of any kind but I
thought it would be good to give you a
brief introduction so dado is a machine
learning platform and our focus is to
help developers and data scientists
build applications that use machine
learning so here's an example
application this is a product
recommender let's see can you guys you
probably can't read that let's try that
is that better and so when I select a
product like a dumb movie like Dumb and
Dumber I'm recommended other dumb movies
like happy gilmore Ace Ventura liar liar
cable guy Tommy Boy black sheep and Big
Daddy how many of you have seen dumb and
dumber the original Dumb and Dumber from
over 20 years ago yeah so do you guys
think these are decent recommendations
for physical comedies from the mid-90s I
have to admit that I've seen almost all
of these at least all the comedies I've
never seen the new nightmare movie but I
don't know if that counts or not so so
what's that yeah rocky five have you
seen rocky five I
it counts as a physical comedy in my
book but because he doesn t in Rocky 5e
fights in front of a public city bus on
the street against Tommy the gun or
something like the like anyway it's like
a protege that goes against him if I
remember correctly so so this is a fun
application right product recommenders
we use these all the time so with dato
you can easily train and deploy these
types of applications a deploy build
this type of application so for this
demonstration we built a recommender
model trained on the Amazon review data
set and deployed this as a service to
AWS and that's what this application is
using so fun example we could take I
could take a live book movie or music
album title it just can't be too current
it's got to be from 2013 in before say
it again catch-22 I didn't know there
was a VHS version from 1970 that's cool
so catch-22 were recommended
slaughterhouse-five a clockwork orange
Sun Also Rises Invisible Man The Great
Gatsby cat's cradle 1984 breakfast of
champions brave new world and heart of
darkness what do you think as
recommendations I could say that like if
you went to high school in in the u.s.
like I did you've probably read half of
these through throughout your your
schooling so probably not too bad so
there we go that's an example let's do a
very different type of application so
let's look at let's look at dresses so
in this application maybe I should zoom
in again you guys can see this a little
bit better so
I need to buy my wife a dress and so how
do I go about doing this today I might
go to a website and type in dress and
then see a bunch of dresses
unfortunately I don't really know
anything about dresses and so when I
hover over them I get these text
descriptions and here I'm seeing the
most important words or significant
words of that text description I still
don't understand any of them though I
don't know the different cuts for a
dress I don't know what glimpsed means I
don't know what any of these things are
but I do know that my wife wants a
cocktail dress so maybe I can filter the
dresses and now I can see that these are
all cocktail dresses but again I still
don't know what actually how do you
describe this dress versus this dress
but you know I know that my wife would
like something like this so when I click
on it I'm immediately shown other
dresses that look similar and if I
Shrunk this a little bit you guys would
see that side by side and so how do we
build this so again this is a simple
application using dado what we did is we
took a deep learning model that was
trained on one data set the image net
research data set and we use that model
to extract features from all of these
images and then using those extracted
features we trained a simpler model a
nearest neighbors model and now when i
select on an imp when i select an image
I'm shown the most similar images to
that image so I'm actually seeing
there's no metadata none of that text
descriptions applied here it's just the
images themselves so that's how we built
this application and this can help
obviously for helping me figure out
which cocktail dress my wife would like
but also in applications where similar
for images is important so this is a
second application again we we built
this using the products that data offers
and we have this deployed in AWS and the
last one will show you is one that's
very relevant to today's tutorial so by
the end of the tutorial you should be
able to build the building blocks for
this demo I can't say you'll be able to
build the UI because I can't build this
UI
but we will at least do the data science
and machine learning part so this demo
is about sentiment analysis using text
from Yelp reviews or Yelp sorry Yelp
debt metadata so I'm in San Francisco
I'm in San Francisco all the time though
dado is based in seattle i spent a lot
of time in san francisco one of the
things i always want to do when i'm in
san francisco is get a good burrito so
what does good mean to me it means I
want it to be an authentic burrito so
when I go to Yelp like all of us have
done I'm sure several times and you go
to look for food that might give you a
burrito you get thousands of reviews how
do you know which reviews are actually
helpful in make in you don't want to
read a thousand reviews you want to read
the 10 reviews that talk about how
authentic the burritos are and that's
pretty hard to do today but if i search
for burrito authentic and dirty because
i don't necessarily want to eat at a
dirty place I get back a score for each
of those keywords from from the
restaurant and so now let's pick one of
these places so let's pick I think this
is the one that I've been to before and
so now when I click on that I now see
this in the individual score for each of
these three words from taqueria
guadalajara and then when i click on
authentic what I see now are the most
positive and negative sentences from all
of the reviews of this restaurant that
refer to authentic does that make sense
so this is a this is sometimes called
aspect mining where you're not looking
for overall sentiment of the entire
review did you like the restaurant or
not instead you're looking for a
specific aspect of the review and then
you want to predict the sentiment of
that aspect so I don't care about the
entire cell phone review I only care
about the battery life of the cell phone
so I want to get the sentiment of the
battery life component
it or sentence of the review does that
make sense and this is what we're going
to get to by the end of today's tutorial
is doing exactly this so what you can
see for this place is for taqueria
guadalajara the most positive sentences
are burritos surprisingly all I remember
from the night is that the burritos
taste authentic not like these other
places the second one one of the best
authentic Mexican food I have ever had
and they talk about all these other
places now let's see what the negative
ones are the first one authentic mexican
food fairly priced but not very clean so
even the negative the negative sentiment
sentences that refer to authentic still
speak positively of the authenticity of
the food so that's that's kind of where
we're going but i wanted to give you
this quick overview of the types of
applications you can build using data
let's get back to a couple more slides
and just in general we're going to do a
few slides then we'll pause for a
hands-on session probably 15 minutes or
so I'll pull the room to make sure folks
are mostly caught up and then we'll move
on to the next section so of course this
isn't the only time you can hear about
you can hear from folks at dedo later
this afternoon Brian's going to be
talking about density based clustering
in Python where some of his recent
research along with some of a some of
the work of other projects in Python
really cool I'm hoping to get to attend
and then tomorrow sean is going to talk
through thinking about machine learning
models in production I'm going to touch
on it briefly today but there's going to
be a lot more depth than Sean's talk
tomorrow so check us out there so what
do I mean by a machine learning
application what what does it mean to
how is this different than data science
today so if you look at data science
today it might look like this you start
with some data could be messy from all
these different places you've got to
clean it up extract features from it
then you're going to split the data set
right so far so good into a training set
and validation
set then you're going to train a model
and you're going to evaluate how all
that models doing based on your
validation set and what's the next thing
you go back to the beginning and start
over again and this is sort of the
iterative loop of data science well this
is subtly different than what I mean by
a machine learning application though it
has a lot of common elements to it this
isn't the end of the process in fact
this is just the beginning of it so
let's walk through the entire process of
building an application that uses
machine learning so you start with
conducting some experiments and you'll
have to excuse my my digitalocean logo
but you always start with data this is
similar so the data science process you
start by exploring it and you start
modeling but you do this in this
iterative loop this is the same as the
data science process but at this point
your goal here is to prototype you're
trying to see is there signal in my data
is there's something worth exploring so
depending on what your application is or
what your goal is if you're looking to
predict if a customer will leave you if
you're looking to predict churn you're
trying to see do I have the right
features do I have the right data do I
have the right model to actually make
this sort of prediction so this is this
iterative prototyping step but your goal
from this prototyping is different when
you're trying to build an application
your goal is to get to a pipeline and
this is where we're going to spend
today's session is talking through the
parts of going from that prototype
through to a pipe to a pipeline so the
first thing you need to do is take your
unstructured data and ingest it so that
it's in a structured form then you're
transforming your data and this is
typically the feature engineering or
feature selection step meaning how do i
change my data and transform it and I'll
drill in on this a little bit more so
that the model so a model can interpret
it your next step is to model train
models and evaluate those models
typically using offline evaluation
criteria and finally to deploy those
models and when you're thinking of
deploying a model there's a kind of the
old school way of doing it which is
taking model and generating predictions
in a batch way and then recording those
predictions somewhere
that's how things have have always been
done but today more more and more people
are looking to take that model and
deploy it as a service so that you can
use it for real time predictions and
make it easy to update the model with
and improve on that model so that's what
we're going to zoom in on so so far so
good right these four steps ingestion
transformation modeling and deployment
these are the four components of a
machine learning application but if you
think about this is building that first
application you're not quite done yet
though because imagine you've got that
first application built and now you're
looking to deploy it so you want to
deploy those models as real time
services or as a REST API so as a set of
services so now you can easily integrate
this model into the rest of your
application chances are your application
is comfortable making web service calls
so this integrating your model is as
easy as integrating another web service
once you've deployed as a service you
want to be able to get feedback from the
model use that that feedback to update
the pipeline or update the model all the
while you're not sitting around idle
you're working on the next version of
this model or the next version of the
pipeline and once you have multiple
pipelines deployed you want to be able
to conduct online experiment so this is
a be testing or multi armed bandits so
this is the complete lifecycle of an m/l
application this make sense everybody
okay with this we're going to zoom in on
these four components though these are
the four components that we're going to
talk about in today's session ingesting
data transforming that data or feature
engineering and feature selection
modeling including some bits on
evaluation and then finally deployment
okay any questions
no everybody so quiet okay go ahead USB
sticks yes we do have them so the
notebook is at that link the data set is
in the US as on the USB sticks anyone
else need USB sticks a few more okay so
maybe we can just Brian if you want to
walk around and all right sweet is that
a question are you looking for go ahead
Python too we're working on Python 3
it'll give give us a few more months
we'll have Python 3 support it's
something we're actively working on it's
a great question any other questions
guys all right we're going to jump right
in but please stop with questions
interrupt me don't don't feel like you
have to listen to me this whole time I
want to hear from you too so the
application that we're going to work on
is using yelp review data so it's about
restaurants very similar to the demo
that i showed you for sentiment analysis
so it's going to take me a while to try
and read these but the goal the first
thing we're going to try and do is
predict if a review is funny or not and
so the thing on the left Rosie Dakota
and I love chip chap Harold dog park I
don't know how to say that it's very
convenient and surrounded by lots of
pads a desert something scape baseball
fields ballparks and a lake with ducks
the Scottsdale Park and Rec Department
does a great wonderful job keeping the
park clean and shaded so is this seem
funny to you guys you're right it is not
funny it's very informative but not very
funny whereas the one on the right the
oldish man who owns the store as if
sweetest can be perhaps sweeter than the
cookies or ice cream here's the lowdown
giant ice cream cookie sandwiches for
super cheap so is this one funny I mean
it's it's funny here right so if we you
know if we don't think of it as early in
the morning we may actually think this
is funny you know with a couple drinks
in us would probably laugh when we read
this so this is what we're going to try
and do is predict whether a review is
funny or not looking at its text
so this is the the we're going to go
through the same application it's one
notebook but we're going to go in pieces
we're going to go through these first
these four components ingestion and
transformation we're going to do that
first then we'll do some modeling then
we're going to talk about sentiment
analysis and then we'll talk and then
we'll deploy so that's the the outline
for today so let's think about data
cleaning or that first step of ingestion
it's really important that you know your
tool this is actually it makes a huge
difference because when you're working
with messy data like most data sets are
if you don't know your tools you'll
spend a lot of time just getting some
basic operations done this is very
similar to your favorite coding
environment your favorite IDE if you
know some shortcuts it can go really you
can go you can be significantly more
productive the same is true when you're
cleaning data so you have lots of
formats even a format that seems as well
understood as CSV is a how do I say it
is a can leave you with some surprises
you can't read that but on the left is a
panda's read CSV so kind of the
workhorse in in pandas for reading text
formats and you can see how many
parameters there are so knowing the
parameters can really help because you
can probably not spend time actually
trying to write little said scripts or
shell scripts to make your data change
its shape so that pandas can read it
instead there's a way to get panda's to
read it as is and on the right you see
the s frame read CSV which is another
open source package it's one that data
offers for out of core tabular data so
again lots of parameters a specific
thing to pay attention to is missing
values and this was really common when
you're looking at data sets missing
values can have lots of different
interpretation so it's important that
you you think about this when when
ingesting data a lot of time spent
cleaning data is just dealing with
missing values and finally use some
visualization tools if you
attended the matplotlib session earlier
today in this room Matt pot lives a
great visualization package it's has
lots and lots of options but your goal
here is to use some statistics to better
understand what your data is like how
much cleaning do you have to do that's
an important thing to think about when
you're when you're getting started with
the project if your data it needs a lot
of cleaning then you may want to think
about ok what's the step prior to
getting this data can i change that step
whether that's an injection pipeline or
the way the data is or is organized so
that my data cleaning becomes easier
maybe it's just as easy as saying hey
you know I don't need this as a CSV the
raw data is in JSON I'll just ingest it
that way or this data is coming from a
database I can just connect to that
database directly and and run queries
against that database directly so think
about that sort of stuff in the data
cleaning part for today's tutorial the
data sets pretty clean I tried to not
it's the raw yelp review data set so it
has a couple warts in it but chances are
your real data is Messier it it probably
needs more cleaning so feature
engineering this is the we're now on to
step 2 this is transformation and really
these these often go hand in hand
because the intent at the end of this
step is to have the data in a format or
have the data ready for the model and so
the the at a high level your goal with
feature engineering and feature
selection is to get your data set
prepared so that the model can
understand it so a simple example is
continuous variables into categorical so
zip code is a great example zip codes a
number it's probably an integer in in
your in your table or in your data
structure but having a greater zip code
like 1000 7 is not actually greater than
1000 6 so that's a really simple thing
but you don't want the model to
interpret a zip code as anything other
than a label and so you want to root you
want to make sure that your
turp reting interpreting columns as
integers only if that you actually
expect that the model to interpret and
to learn that that's a continuous
variable where a bigger number actually
means something otherwise you want it to
simply be a categorical variable or a
label so day of the month is another one
where that that's an important thing or
the year really common examples so
another pretty standard feature
engineering technique is to create
aggregates and so you often don't need
the exact number an example of this
could be your age where your age is
actually a continuous variable so being
50 means something other than being 30
but you may not actually care about how
many 50 year olds verses 51 versus 52
you may want to quantize or bucket eyes
so 18 to 34 year olds 35 to 50 year old
like that that's a really common feature
engineering technique because again the
specific number isn't important but a
range or a bucket is more important the
same for text so you might have a full
document maybe you only care at the
sentence level or maybe you actually
only care to look at n grams so to buy
grams which are two words two words that
are next to each other in a sentence or
three words that are next to each other
next to each other in a document and so
for a lot of different techniques it's
this sort of manipulation that's what
this sort of transformation is what
you're doing for feature engineering now
we talked about missing values what do
you do when you have them so often times
you want to impute missing values or you
want to essentially fill in missing
values using something else so a
standard is to use an aggregate so i
will take the average value in this data
set and fill that in for all of the
values that are missing not sure if that
that works in every problem but that's a
pretty standard way of doing things
where you take an aggregate or you say
okay what's the mean what's one standard
deviation lower I'll make all my missing
values that or more complex example
would be to use separate
learning model to predict the missing
value so this is also really common as
you're building up these model pipelines
that if you have missing values and
missing values are there's no way around
them you may be able to train a model to
predict the missing value and then use
that to fill in your missing values and
finally and we're going to do a tiny bit
of this I call this use data encoding as
new features so you might have lots of
data so the idea of using an encoding
can you guys you guys can see that okay
is let me let me try and give an example
so if you're thinking of think of user
profiles for for Facebook for example or
for a social network there are lots and
lots of fields lots of metadata about
each user now do you want to think of
each of those features independently or
as do you want it is it actually
important that each of those features be
considered by the model maybe not you
may be able to get away with simply
saying I want to hash for all of these
features and I only want this to be in I
only want to use 15 bits to represent
this hash so that's a way of reducing
the dimensionality of the problem taking
away some of those features but still
getting a representative hash for those
feature values so that would be feature
hashing so that's what i mean by
encoding your data as another feature
and so this way you can avoid using all
the specific values for something for
all the specific features and instead
use an encoding and what we'll use today
is one hot encoding which is a technique
for the way we're using it is to reduce
dimensionality where we'll say given
this entire corpus or all the entire
vocabulary of these texts reviews i only
want the top five thousand words so that
means there might be 20,000 words
vocabulary of 20,000 words used across
the corpus of reviews but i only want
the the 5,000 words that are used most
commonly that's a really simple way of
reducing the dimensionality so that the
the model can learn more easily does
this make sense in terms of what we're
doing a feature engineering and feature
selection
okay so now we're going to I'm going to
switch over and jump to using the
notebook that if you haven't gotten yet
you can still get from this link and
we'll start by doing these some
operations in using the s frame now you
can pip install the s frame it's a
Python package it's open source it's
also part of GraphLab create and since
we'll use GraphLab create for later in
the tutorial my notebook doesn't use s
frame directly it uses it as part of
GraphLab create and then we'll use
GraphLab canvas which is a data
visualization tool it's part of GraphLab
create to give you a sense of the data
so sound good so all right we're going
to switch over to a notebook can you
guys read that that seem right I'm going
to go fullscreen and then get rid of
these headers so full screen
so how many of you are familiar with
ipython notebook or Jupiter notebook
almost everybody okay good so then I
won't really cover this so we're going
to use a since we're using s frame to do
our ingestion s James part of GraphLab
create I'll just import GraphLab to get
started you guys can all read this right
this okay okay I say this but it's
actually hard for me to read this let me
see if I can do the angle of the laptop
is not awesome nope all right we're just
gonna do this don't mind me staring down
at my maybe I'll do that I'll look at
that okay better okay step one is
loading the data so i have this so you
can also see where this data set came
from so you can download it as a zip
file or you can grab it off the USB key
if you haven't gotten it already and i
have this as a JSON file written on my
file system so i'm going to call read
csv which actually can read JSON and can
read anything else and I can change this
to JSON but will read CSV and there's no
header row in this so we'll run this to
do oh come on scroll so this file has
229,000 rose and we parsed it in two
seconds let's look at a row so a
specific row from our from the s frame
so the s frame is a tabular data
structure so one of the rows from that
table what you can see is this is one
big JSON document yes
i'm not using pandas for two reasons the
s frames is I could use pandas I'm less
familiar with the pandas API I'm more
familiar with the SRAM API they're very
similar yeah pandas were very so pandas
was inspired by the our data frame and
the s frame is inspired by both the
pandas and the our data frame the
biggest distinction is the s frame is an
out-of-court data structure so pandas
requires your data to fit into Ram
whereas the s frame does not so you can
work on larger data sets so on this
laptop we could work on a terabyte of
data because even though I only have 16
gigs of RAM on the laptop because it's
an out-of-court data structure and it's
the data structure that GraphLab create
relies on for its models so when we get
to doing sentiment analysis models and a
little bit then we need to be using an s
frame you can have obviously convert a
pandas dataframe into an s frame and
vice versa but might as well use 11
system does that make sense great
question honestly I wish I knew pandas
better because pandas does have more
options in the s frame today for
ingestion but for this problem we're
okay we see that this is a JSON document
so this JSON document has one column and
if we look at we can look at the column
types
and you see that there's just one column
and it's a type dictionary so GraphLab
or the s frame was able to ingest the
the JSON file and realize that each row
was a single JSON document which in
Python is encoded as a dictionary so far
so good right so let's let's start let's
actually get this into something usable
so this is it's not horribly dirty but
this isn't how we want to model and
remember our first goal is to predict
funny or not that's our first goal is
given the text can we predict if this
this review is funny so each review is a
JSON document let's unpack it so we with
this command we're basically saying take
the column that's named x1 and we want
to unpack it with no prefix so let me
show you where what this looks like now
so it's a little hard to read but you
can see that we've unpacked so now
business ID date review ID he scroll
over and scroll back stars text type and
there's a few more columns actually but
you see this is exactly what we had
before business ID date review ID but
these were headers or these were nested
JSON inside the outer JSON document so
we've just peeled back or exploded that
outer layer JSON so now we have these
columns and we're halfway there I lost
my cursor okay
ah let's see so the next thing we notice
is that the votes so Yelp reviews are
great because people have actually they
vote on the reviews but those are
trapped inside a nested JSON document
inside this so let's unpack it one more
time and then let's look at what our
data structure looks like now what our
table looks like so you see so far it
looks the same but let me scroll down
and now you can see that the three types
of votes cool funny and useful are all
exploded so now we have one table so now
our data is kind of ready there's still
some more things we want to do but this
is actually closer to how we want the
data to be represented because we're
going to take advantage of this funny
column so if someone's voted a review is
funny then that's what our model should
learn right it should predict that a
review is funny using this label go
ahead Sarah question yep
that is right in fact we're going to do
that in two steps we're going to do some
logical filtering some group buys some
joins we're not going to do joins in
group buys today but we'll do some
filtering as part of our feature
engineering step okay so GraphLab canvas
is our visualization and data
exploration tool I could do all of these
operations from the from from the s
frame itself so getting full getting
aggregates getting stats but it's
sometimes easier and maybe I should zoom
out on this screen to just look at the
data using canvas so what's happened in
the background is we've done a one-pass
sketch summary over each column what
this means is using some pretty clever
sketching techniques we've in one pass
have been able to provide approximate
statistics so this went really quickly
230,000 rose but if you have 10 million
rows this goes it's still at interactive
speeds and the advantage here is when
you're in this step when you're
ingesting and cleaning your data you
often don't care about the exact mean of
a numeric value the average but you an
approximate average is good enough or
looking at a standard distribution or a
box and whiskers plot of something of a
numeric field a numeric feature or
numeric column you want to get a sense
of the distribution the exact
distribution is less important an
approximate is good enough so what we
see here is when we look at stars we see
that there's five unique values this
makes sense 125 so the min is one the
max is 5 the median is 4 and the mean is
3.7 so what does this tell us if we
click on it we should see a histogram
here as tells us that most people give a
review three or better and so that's an
important thing most people don't write
more people write positive reviews than
people write negative reviews and so
that's useful to us or actually if you
look at that was looking at it
numerically if we look at it
categorically this is what you want to
see that the most common review is for
stars 30 almost thirty five percent
followed by five stars at thirty-three
percent so at sixty-seven percent over
two-thirds of the reviews or four or
five stars so that's important to know
okay so this is the type of thing you
can do with canvas it's why it's useful
you can also just scroll through the
data which is also useful 220,000 rose
isn't a lot you could do this in Excel
you could use vim and probably poke
around a bit and just just be fine but
when you have 10 million rows this can
actually prove to be pretty useful and
the paging in and out is a is because of
the s frame okay and some basic plots
which I won't cover but in this tutorial
but is also useful in this exploration
phase let's see if we can do something
like user ID and stars I don't know if I
want to bar chart maybe I do so yeah
these are all different user IDs I can
scroll through them stars is not what I
count yes so this tells you this user
had 498 reviews and the that's amazing
so you can see this that there's a
distribution the number of users that
write reviews is also varies quite a bit
okay so that's that's s Frank that's
canvas let's get back to our notebook ah
the full screen thing makes this here we
go this is where we were ok so we got a
sense of our data we see that there's
definitely more positive reviews four
and five star reviews than anything else
but what we want to do is get to to
predicting funny so let's filter out
reviews that have no votes so first
let's create a new feature called total
votes which is the sum of the number of
votes number of votes given saying a
review as funny plus cool plus useful so
this is the total number of votes so
it's kind of like how many people gay
said anything voted in any way about a
review so let's do that and we assign
this to a new
column in our table so we've created a
new feature now now let's filter out and
this is what what you were mentioning
before let's filter out all the rows
that have no votes so in other words we
don't want to learn on something that
maybe no one's ever seen so we want to
take away all of the all of that data so
that's a logical filter so I'm saying
give me the reviews table give me all
the reviews where total votes are
greater than zero so we'll do that and
then finally actually here let's pause
for a second and show you what what what
reviews looks like now so it has the
same shape the main difference you'll
see is that there's less data now so we
used to have 229,000 rose let's uh the s
frame is lazily evaluated so it only
does what it needs to so i need to
actually get the length of this to get a
sense of how many rows we have now so
now our table has a hundred and
forty-seven thousand rows so we just
took out 80 thousand reviews because no
one maybe no one's ever seen them no
one's voted on them in any way this way
this does this make sense this is a form
of feature selection where I'm not I'm
going to remove some data from my data
set because it because I don't want to
consider it when training and finally
let's binarize funny so right now funny
represents the number of votes the
number of for a given review the number
of times that review has been voted
funny well I'm just going to say if if
that number is greater than zero I want
it to be one in other words I'm saying
true or false you're either funny or not
and so if you have a vote of that review
has ever been voted funny whether it's
once or ten times just consider it funny
does this make sense good we're going to
do that and now we're going to just cut
all the other stuff out of our table so
we're going to we're only going to
select these two columns the text column
and the funny column
so you can see what my table looks like
now I just have text and I have funny
we're funny is either 0 or 1 now I have
the data I want to train my model go
ahead sure maybe halogen boards but 181
that is funny right and then we have to
be stupid to be funny it's a good
question so the so the question was what
if the review has a thousand words in it
and only one of them is actually what
makes the review funny or one of the
words is considered funny how are we
accounting for that so remember our goal
here was to predict whether the entire
review is funny or not whether or not
that so if it's a thousand words that's
fine if that thousand words you know at
the end of it your sentiment is this is
a funny review my question is for
example get a thousand words right okay
so that's a different different question
so you're saying give how many people
saw this review and of the people that
saw the reviews maybe a thousand people
saw it only one person voted the review
is funny right we don't know how many
people saw these reviews our only
indication of interaction is based on
the votes of useful funny or what was
the third one cool and so we don't
actually know seen whether these reviews
have been seen so are our closest
interpretation of that is if you have no
votes of any kind then maybe you've
never been seen as a review so we
actually aren't considering the case of
well only one person thought this was
funny but and for our predictor I think
this is okay it's not weighted that's
correct we're not waiting we're saying
either you're funny or not and we're
only saying you're funny if anyone ever
thought you were funny ever there was
another question nope
the data sparse if only this first
episode
good question so the question was how do
you deal with really sparse data a few
different there's lots of options here
one is you want to adjust class weights
so another standard is you want to
balance so if you only have a thousand
labeled samples and you have 10,000
unlabeled you want to sample from the
unlabeled so that you have a balanced
set of data so those are two really
common techniques also your data
structures themselves should be good
with sparse data so you should do you
should be able to represent us you
should leverage sparse data structures
to represent sparse data otherwise it's
much less efficient there's a great
question and any other questions is
everybody following along am I going to
slowly should I speed up no this is good
okay i'm happy to speed up but i
probably would be less coherent okay so
now we've got the raw text and a
binarized version of if a review is
funny or not but how do we interpret
that text so let's do a couple things to
give ourselves a better representation
of each review in fact let's break the
text into a bag of words representation
bag of words or a frequency count so
instead we want to see for each word in
a given so we want to see so given a
review we want to see how many times
each word was used in that review so
this is a frequency count for the words
inside a review so here we'll use a text
analytics tool or toolkit in GraphLab
create and we'll just pull out will do
count words you could also do this in
scikit-learn with count vectorize ER and
i even have a i even tried to do this
this morning I was thinking I should
have both I should have both with oh no
where is it I had another notebook which
is not here oh here it is logistic
regression once I could learn but I
didn't get far enough along but you can
do the same thing using the count
vectorize ER
a function in socket learning I already
have this open why are you opening it
again huh weird ok we'll open this again
and attitude ok so we're going to do
this we wrote this as a little Python
function because we're going to use it
more than once we need this and this is
thinking this is looking a little bit
ahead but if you're thinking about how
do i create a pipeline think of you want
to think about the the goal being the
application you're creating the goal is
this is amazing like selecting text and
I'm not looking to oh well the goal is
given some text I want to predict like
given the text of a new review I want to
predict if that review is funny or not
so all the operations that you need to
do on the text itself will need to be
repeated you'll want to do this at
prediction time so it makes sense to
write the these operations as functions
so that you can easily sort of do that
that the the pipeline of those steps
those pre-processing steps prior to
getting a prediction from the model this
make sense so let's run this Wow ok
let's get rid of that do that
okay so so I talked about one hot and
coding before this is what it looks like
if you're using the one hot encoding
transformer and GraphLab create there's
a there's a an equivalent and
scikit-learn and so the goal here is
given this oh so let's look at the
review data before we do this so we just
define the function let's why let's try
reloading my browser is not behaving the
way I expect I've lost all my shortcuts
in ipython notebook which I am kind of
useless without okay should still be
running I should let's make sure i have
shortcuts I don't all right we'll keep
going without shortcuts but I'm so much
slower with ipython notebook if I don't
have keyboard shortcuts there do all
right okay so let's insert a cell below
this and let's run this function on our
review data set
oh maybe my keyboard has stopped working
that's amazing Wow ok well let's run
this cell and then I'll give you guys a
few minutes to work on this I just want
to see my output while I figure out what
what happened to my system all right
I'll explain this and then I'll debug my
system while you guys can spend a few
minutes making sure that you're at this
point before we move on to the modeling
step but the key thing I'm doing here
and this is where this max categories
comes in is all the reviews the 147,000
that we have left they probably use a
pretty big vocabulary meaning there
could easily be 10,000 or 100,000 words
in this vocabulary maybe not a hundred
thousand maybe 50,000 but I actually
don't want to try and use all of them so
I only want to keep the top five
thousand words and that's what my one
hot encoding what the one hot encoder
feature engineering transformer enables
me to do and so this this is a stateful
transformer like most of the feature
engineering transformers so in a way it
feels like a model so you want to fit
and then again you want to be able to
transform because you'll have to do this
at prediction time and that's why this
is an important thing so remember that
you're taking a raw document raw review
and you want to predict whether it's
funny or not but you'll only want to
count the words in that review that that
are in the top five thousand from your
training set so that's why it's stateful
so so we ran that and now we're ready to
train and I really want to show you what
this looks like but I've lost my
keyboard and so I'm going to debug this
so give me a second to do this you guys
should definitely follow along make sure
you're at this point so then we can
switch back to slides and I'll talk
through modeling the model that will
train and then we'll come back and keep
working on this let's give me just a
second
so what do you do when you have windows
and something doesn't work you turn it
off and on again you buy a Mac yes but
then how do you test whether your
company's product runs on windows those
aren't users you want to support that's
that's funny yeah we said the same thing
about 32-bit users that yeah who has a
32-bit computer these days turns out
lots of people have 32-bit computers
still lots of company settings still
have 32-bit images that was a lesson we
learned we still don't work on 32-bit
machines yeah it's a good question the
question was weird where does our stuff
run so it always starts from your laptop
because that's where you're starting
with all the prototyping so from your
laptop to a server to a cluster so
remember since it's out of core you're
not limited by ram so you can work on
much much larger data sets on your
laptop so so yeah terabytes of data on
your rent on your laptop which typically
actually lets you cover a lot of a lot
of the data that you're using all right
start by launching I've got a keyboard
again which is a good sign let's uh I
don't want to restore pages
come on
on the book and
haha I have a keyboard again yeah all
right let's catch up
ok this is kind
amazing okay
ok so it's 1135 is everybody that wants
to be caught up to this point at this
point you don't have to be you can just
passively follow along but if you want
to be caught up and go hands-on then I
want to make sure you get a chance to
catch up if you're still having trouble
or you're stuck on something raise your
hand and Brian can swing by and chat
with you Brian's back there to the side
so I want to talk about modeling next so
so far where are we in this process well
we ingested some data there's JSON
review data we transformed it so now we
we we've gotten the text and you know
what I should show you this this is one
thing I wanted to show you that before
my laptop went haywire let me show you
what what the data looks like now after
we completed this this encoding stat so
so if we look at train so this is our
review table well after we ran this
select features function to get a bag of
words representation so now text is the
same review but now with a frequency
count on each word so you can see that
this first review said better looks go
each with only a count of 1 and then
let's look at encoded which is after
we've done the one hot encoding what
what things look like then
so what you can see here is that I have
a numeric value now with accounts of 14
these top five thousand words so that's
the encoding that I'll learn ok let me
get rid of this header but I won't go
into full screen just cuz I don't like
full screen it's more confusing for me
alright so let's get back to modeling
now let's talk about the actual machine
learning model the model that we want to
train so modeling's that core component
of anything you're doing with machine
learning and a very simple way of
thinking about it is a model is a
simplified view of your data so you're
thinking of a simplified representation
or a way you can consider your data in a
more simplified form than actually using
all of your data and so I like this
quote all models are wrong but some are
useful so that's a good guiding
principle when you're thinking about
modeling so I only want to talk through
I'll talk through one model and I'll do
this pictorially there's lots of
resources available that can do a better
job than I can to go through logistic
regression but this is the the model
that will use it's a linear classifier
meaning the way that I think of this is
that you're fitting a line to a set of
data points so if you have a bunch of
data points you're you're finding the
mathematical function that most closely
reaches those data points that's the
idea of a linear model and the and when
I say most closely you're minimizing the
error that you have from the data points
and you don't want and so that's the
idea that we're fitting a line to our
data so let's look at it in the context
of funny and not funny whether based on
the number of stars and the number of
votes were useful for a review
so what does a linear model learn what
is it learning well it learns a weight
for each of these features so stars is a
feature useful is a feature and when you
when you give both of these model both
of these features to the model it's
going to learn a weight so
mathematically if you're thinking of how
do you define a line y equals MX plus B
right B is your intercept M is your
coefficient and X is the is the variable
well this is the exact same thing right
except you're looking at a polynomial so
many coefficients 1 / feature and Brian
correct me if I'm getting this wrong by
the way so far so good good so so what
are we learning what what the model
learns is the weight for each feature
meaning and so the idea here is we're
trying to minimize so we have a label we
know whether something is should be
considered funny or not so we want given
that data we want to fit a line that is
as close to the correctly predicting
funny while incorporating all of the the
other features so the idea that this
model could learn that stars has a
negative 3 wait this feature has a
negative 3 weight and useful has a
positive 1 wait so now how are these
weights this is what the model the train
model actually has or it has learned
these weights for each feature so what
is this what how does how do you use
this at prediction time so pictorially
you always start with your constant
that's going to stay the same and you
you multiply the weight by the value in
the data this is exactly the MX plus B
right so if you know m m is the weight x
is the value so we'll do that we do the
same for useful and we see that this is
too since it's greater than 0 right
logistic
aggression 021 since it's greater than
zero we are now funny that we're going
to predict this review is funny let's do
the inverse case if you take five look I
can't point at this this isn't useful
you guys can't see this if we take five
and two and do the exact same thing we
now see we're negative we're at minus 13
that's less than zero this review is not
funny so this give you an intuition of
what logistic regression is doing and
how we apply it good so what about
categorical variables so so far we
talked about these as continuous
variables where five stars is better
than one star but what about when you
have day of the month or or words how do
you in how does logistic regression work
with these types of variables remember
categorical variables are like labels
you know like zip code or we're having a
greater value there is no such thing as
a greater value well logistic regression
does this by creating a feature per
category so if you have a categorical
variable say you have day of the month
so day can be 1 20 through 30 or 0
through 31 I guess 0 through 30 you
would have a feature or a column for
each of those each of those available
days and so does that make sense where
it what we're getting at then is if the
value if day equals 1 then that means
the day 1 column would have a one and
all the other day columns would have
nothing so there's a feature per
category of your categorical variable so
this is why cutting down the number of
words in the vocabulary of the review is
important because each of those becomes
a feature in training our model go ahead
so this is what the models learning as
it's going through the data as its
training is it's minimizing the error on
the from the labeled column so from the
weather the review is funny or not and
so this is what it's this is what the
models learned so the way to think of
this is at the end of training this is
what the model is captured it is
captured weights for each of these
variables each and so for categorical
variables in logistic regression the way
to think of it is it's one feature per
category of each categorical variable
does this make sense this is important
for how we're dealing with reviews which
is why we wanted one hot encoding
because we said we only want the top
five thousand words because each of
those words is a categorical variable
and we we're going to have a feature for
each one
well you can only be one of those days
meaning the raw data set say it say it
was day of month and it had values from
0 to 30 the when when you're creating
one feature per category there will be
30 columns or 31 columns and only one of
them will have a 1 the rest will all be
0 does that make sense another question
yeah go ahead
good question did did I get rid of
important words or what's common words
often called stop words in NLP I didn't
in this example but you could easily do
that so you can you can drop the stop
words you could do some better
tokenization of the strings but for this
example as you'll see in a few minutes
it's okay I didn't want us to spend a
whole bunch of time just trying to clean
the text how much can you get like how
good is that first application that
first model when we don't do a lot of
sophisticated NLP stuff you can always
go back and do more but that's a good
example that's a good idea dropping
punctuation or expanding punctuation so
don't becomes do not like that was there
another question in the back go ahead
this is a raw count yoona grams so this
is just frequency count of each word so
we're not looking at by grams or trigons
though we certainly could go ahead good
question so the question was how do you
choose the model why do we pick linear
regression or logistic regression for
this problem it's a good question i
think the the i could probably spend a
whole hour talking about that that
there's that that is the but one of the
simple things here is what's our task is
this a funny review or not so the minute
you're making a binary decision you want
to model that that that does that sort
of classification that does that sort of
prediction so that's why this seems
natural to use I want to predict 0 or 1
and that's what logistic regression
model helps me predict so i'm using
GraphLab create for all the modeling and
here's why a lot of machine learning
packages allow you to require you to
transform your data into a sparse matrix
or into thinking about it in in matrix
form so that the model can interpret it
and then you have to go back and remap
to your raw data once the models trained
and that's that's a nuisance and it can
get in the way because you now you're
maintaining this translation in your
code that is just one more thing to
maintain so with GraphLab create we
don't have to do that we can take s
frames like the one we've been working
on and the the models do sensible things
with any of the data types so you don't
have to do this additional step and the
the input can be sparse dense you don't
have to think about matrices you don't
have to think about how the model itself
is implemented in order to to work with
your data and of course everything's
it's out of course so you can work on
data much larger than memory and we of
course think our our system is robust
and we pick a solver for you and for
more complex models that makes a lot of
sense that's an important consideration
what's the solver you can select a
solver but we'll pick one for you based
on the shape of your data so this
makes this allows the optimization step
to be one that you don't have to
research up front you can just get
started and then you can improve it or
look more carefully at which solver
you'd like to use but you don't have to
pick one at the outset so a question
so good question so the question was how
do you choose which solver and it
depends on the model and so for each
model we sort of document the process
for picking the solver does that help at
yeah that's probably the simplest way to
describe it okay so now let's get back
to the notebook and actually do some
modeling and so we're a weird 11-50 and
we only go to 1210 so I'm going to speed
up a little bit on this part so guys
stop me if I'm going to too fast what we
talked through training a logistic
regression model now let's actually
train it so logistic classifier meaning
we want to classify we're not going to
use a validation set or data sets not
that big by default graph lab-created
will take five percent of your data set
and use it for validation we're not
going to use that we're going to take
this encoded s frame this one that I
just showed you a moment ago that looks
like this this is what we're going to
train on and the target column isn't
labeled funny so that's what this funny
what the second parameter is so let's
run that and somewhere between ipython
notebook and Jupiter we lost the
incremental output in ipython notebook
so I only see output now when it's done
even though we have progress statements
they just don't appear anymore we have
to figure out why so let's see what we
found 147,000 examples there's two
classes you're either funny or not
there's only one column with features
and there's exactly five thousand
features this makes sense is exactly
what we did with one hot encoding max
categories of 5,000 we have exactly five
thousand features because logistic
regression will create a feature for
every category in your categorical
variable we only have one categorical
variable which is the the encoded
feature so we trained 10 iterations now
let's look at what we got back as our
train model
it's a logistic classifier excuse me a
couple of the hyper parameters l1 and l2
penalty for regularization we have some
same defaults we can just go with them
these are obviously things you can tune
and make make better 5.7 seconds for us
to train and then you can see the most
positive coefficient and most negative
coefficient and these are the encoded
encoded words so we're done now we've
now got a model now let's set it up so
it's easy for us to evaluate how well
this models doing so that's what this
this function is so this is in a way
this is the whole pipeline so now given
text we want to return yes or no whether
it's funny so what do we do we take the
text we're given we create an s frame
out of it we then call that select
features a function that we wrote
earlier to get the bag of words
representation we then use the one hot
encoder that we fit earlier to transform
that bag of words representation in
other words only keep the top 5 only
keep the words in the review that are in
our top five thousand words from our
training set and then use that in that
transformed review to classify and call
classify on the model and then take
those results and just add a column to
make it easier to interpret that if your
class 0 then you're not funny if your
class 1 then you're funny so that's our
little function and let's let's run
through some qualitative examples so
what do you guys think is this funny do
you think this will be funny or not
it is not funny but it's not super
confident on that it only has a
sixty-two percent probability of not
being funny and what you'll find is for
this very basic funny predictor the
probabilities are not great either way I
wouldn't deploy this to production if
you guys have a real application for
predicting funny I would do some more
sophisticated stuff but for today's
tutorial I think this is good are you
sure this isn't the greatest review ever
even this is not funny certainly seemed
funny to me holy cow amazing food and
really cute servers funny or not yes it
is funny with fifty six percent
probability and this is definitely not
funny is definitely not funny so so
qualitatively what do you guys think
it's a reasonable predictor it's good
enough we should move on to sentiment
analysis go ahead question
yeah that's a good question I should be
able to get back to that I just
certainly we can what I did in my set of
s frame operations is i nuked the the
actually I could I could join oh I could
join my train table which has the words
with my actually wait maybe I can get
back to the encoder so I should be able
to recover this I just don't have it in
my notebook so that that's a really good
point I should go back and see what are
the most positive words but I can get I
can i can give you the spoiler alert its
curse words so if you start cursing
you're going to have a funny review and
we'll get to that so so far we've done
we've done this logistic classifier for
funny or not let's instead step back and
think about overall sentiment so so so
far let's talk about sentiment analysis
and we'll do this quickly because I
think do you guys all have an intuition
of what sentiment analysis is we want
the emotional or subjective meaning of
text is is this person's review positive
about the restaurant or negative that's
the way to think of it and this does
require NLP unfortunately for a lot of
problems there's no there's no score no
one has voted that this is this person
says this is a positive review or not
this is why I on Amazon you get hounded
like which review was it helpful was it
not was it helpful was it not it's so
that you're labeling that data so that
Amazon can then better understand what
the overall sentiment is of that product
which reviews to show you the same thing
Yelp is doing it's your often lacking
the score and so what do you do about
that I'm going to talk about that next
modeling this is incredibly similar to
what we've just done we're going to use
a bag of words representation and we're
going to train a logistic classifier
again where when you get to one that's
absolute maximum positive sentiment and
when you get to when you're at zero
that's negative sentiment so in between
zero and one but here's our challenge
there's no target how do we develop a
target no one has a no one has told us
whether this text is funny or not we
don't have anything labeled one approach
could be to cluster we could try
different modeling technique let's
cluster documents together and see which
documents are similar and if you want to
find out more about clustering come to
brians talk later this afternoon it's
all about clustering and using density
based methods for clustering
unfortunately if we go down this
approach we don't actually analyze the
sentiment we've just found similar
documents that still doesn't help us
with the actual labeling challenge of is
this is this review and all of its
similar reviews positive or not so let's
try a second solution can we find can we
use somebody else's data that's been
labeled can we find an appropriate data
source that is relevant or not entirely
relevant but similar and can we leverage
that one instead it's a pretty common
technique if I don't have labeled data
but you do maybe I can use your data in
conjunction with my problem so I don't
have to label the data so this is what
we're going to do with sentiment
analysis with GraphLab create we offer a
pre train sentiment analysis model you
can always train using your own label if
you have labeled data otherwise we have
a pre train model that's been trained
using twenty percent of random amazon
review data and the amazon review data
has a score and version 5 of the yelp
dataset using stars the number of stars
as the target we binarize these features
so greater than three became one less
than three became 0 and three like
you're absolutely neutral in your review
or your score we discarded and from our
observation using validation sets we got
88 to ninety percent accuracy but
there's more details I should
or about this and we have obvious
limitations here only English and these
this works best if your if your
documents are roughly the same size
question oh yeah so good question how do
we get the Amazon data two ways one
Stanford published from nineteen ninety
six to twenty thirteen it's a snap data
set from the snap group and then it's
been updated by a researcher at UCSD I
think his name is Julian McCauley and
that takes you through 2014 so this data
set is publicly available and I wish I
could say we had some secret sauce to
get it but we didn't and we document
where we got it from and anybody else
can get it too so uh and then the more
advanced technique of I've sentiment
analysis is often called aspect mining I
don't really like that name it seems
like a weird name to me but the intent
here is to I don't care about the whole
review I don't want overall sentiment I
want sentiment about part of the review
the part that talks about something I
care about so I showed you in the demo
burrito and authentic so I care about
authentic and burrito I only want to see
the parts of the review that talk about
those things and I want to predict the
sentiment about those things in the
review so that's uh so this is more
advanced again you can train your own
model or you can use the pre train model
and typically for aspect mining you want
to split your document into sentences
but not always maybe if you're looking
at tweets you will actually want the
whole tweet but for the example we'll
work through we'll split the reviews in
two sentences because that's more
important go ahead of course so natural
language there's lots of ways so the
tokenization of the string in order to
do aspect mining your knee to tokenize
the string create a reverse index that
tokenization leverages natural language
right so we're using the NLT k punked
tokenizer you could also use there's a
bunch of different organizers but this
leverages the grammar of the
language which is why it only works for
English and so so I've got this in the
notebook I'm thinking in the interest of
time I'll plow ahead and finish the
slides in the next five minutes where we
cover deployment and then we can spend
the last bit of time actually working
through both sentiment analysis and
deployment in one shot instead of
switching back and forth so far we've
talked about modeling so let's finally
talk about deployment so I'm going to
give a really quick overview and I
encourage you to come to Sean's talk
tomorrow he's going to go through a lot
more depth but what's your goal when
you're thinking about production you're
thinking about integrating this model
that you've trained with the rest of
your application you want to be able to
update the model with new data so say
you're training nightly or hourly you
want to make that update process
seamless and then of course you want to
make the improvement or increment the
next version of the model you want to
make that deployment seamless and easy
as well you want to make sure you can
use the system for real-time predictions
meaning it's got to have low latency and
you want to be able to use the same
system for online experimentation a be
testing multi-armed bandit so that your
system becomes adaptive so with data
predictive services we have we have a
product that gives you all of these
things and that's what we'll go through
in the notebook so I don't need to cover
all the details here but it makes it
makes doing the the the steps for
deploying a model as a service really
straightforward and easy okay so that's
it for deployment and that's it in terms
of content but let's get through the
notebook
so training the sentiment analysis the
very first thing is we have labeled data
right we know whether something's funny
or not so i don't have to do my bag of
words anymore i don't have to do my i
don't have to do bag of words anymore i
can instead just train this directly it
took a little bit longer because it
didn't do the i didn't use the one hot
encoding but i'm still done and you can
see that I've gotten the way this model
was trained was a bag of words plus a
logistic classifier so now i can predict
on this model given a some text so I
wrote the chicken was bland and
unfortunately undercooked the server was
prompt but the food was not served hot
this is not funny now how about this one
holy cow the server spit in my face but
damn that was a tasty burrito that's
pretty funny and so we can always
calculate the overall accuracy by
evaluating against the entire data set
and of course on a larger data set a
real problem you want to hold out some
data and use that for evaluation but
here we are ninety-four percent accurate
from our entire data from from Archer
from our data set ok so the pre-trained
model let's let's use that one instead
and see how well we do so I'm going to
load my data again but I don't have to
do all the same steps my raw data so you
see that I just have this text column
that's the only thing I have now and
I'll call sentiment analysis if you
don't specify a target we're going to
use the pre-trained model because we
don't have a label so we're done by the
way I should have mentioned all the
stuffs happening on my laptop so there's
no there's no magic server sitting
somewhere so you can see this time this
model looked at all the data it didn't
didn't take things that only had votes
had some votes or not is all 230,000
rose again bag of words with logistic
regression how did we do for overall
sentiment because now we're not trying
to predict funny because we don't have
that label anymore we're now trying to
predict overall
sentiment about the review so it turns
out my my chicken was bland is a is not
a positive sentiment that sounds right
but my holy cow the server spit in my
face but damn that was a tasty burrito
that is a positive sentiment but it's
not as high as using the sentiment
analysis classifier with the funny label
so if I was trying to predict funny
that's better than if I'm just trying to
predict overall sentiment whether it's
positive or negative about the about the
the sentiment of the review about the
restaurant and finally aspect mining
this takes a couple minutes this will
take a minute to train because it's
creating a reverse index first it parses
and then creates a reverse index so
we're splitting by sentence we're again
using just the raw text in the reviews
and I care so for this example I care
about the most positive sentences that
were that talk about teriyaki and rice
in the restaurant review I happen last
night I wanted teriyaki so this is what
I thought about when I was working on
the notebook and then also the most
negative and finally we can get an
overall summary and when I ran this last
night it took about a minute and eight
seconds to train the model so we'll let
that keep going and I won't get time to
cover the deployment stuff but you can
see exactly what you need to do set up
so if you want to do this on your laptop
you set up AWS credentials tell us where
and how many instances you want to
launch in your deployment of predictive
services one command to launch the
cluster and all this runs in your
account we don't have access to your
data or anything like that and when you
set your AWS grant roles they don't go
anywhere they were just setting
environment variables on your machine
you're making all the commands to ec to
directly from from your laptop so you
can see we we easily can add this funny
predictor function that we used before
as a service and give it an endpoint
that becomes the rest api and then we
can apply changes and now query this
using a built in python library or you
could just as easily
query from any just a REST API so you
could query from any client and this
what I deployed here was the funny
predictor so not any of the newer
sentiment analysis models we just
trained but the very first thing we did
which was predicting whether something
was funny or not and so that's it let's
see if my models done training I'm happy
to take questions and I'm certainly here
for the rest of the conference who you
can do all the assignments using other
tools as well but you can also use data
which you can get an academic license
for and as free so this is a great way
to get deeper this is a case study based
approach to machine learning so you
don't start with proofs you start with
applications and then you work then then
the math gets introduced slowly so it's
a much more natural way or more applied
way and and the feedback we've gotten
has been really positive and of course
finally come to brians talk this
afternoon he's a better speaker than I
am and and it comes to Sean's talk
tomorrow and of course you can reach out
to me I've got my email address on the
slide and I'd love to hear from you come
to our table out in the hallway if you
want to find out more about data thanks
so much for your attention guys and
thanks for the questions
you